OK, Donald Trump, again, is saying that Corona
virus is dying out and it's just going to
go away.
Donald Trump was interviewed yesterday about
his upcoming rally in Tulsa, Oklahoma.
Disastrous idea.
Dr. Anthony Foushee says, I wouldn't go to
any large events, including this rally.
Just not a good idea and not a smart idea
as a pandemic is still continuing to rage.
Donald Trump said now the rally is fine because
Corona virus is dying out.
Coronavirus cases are rising in 22 states,
including Oklahoma, where you plan to hold
a big rally this week.
Aren't you afraid about people getting sick?
No, because if you look, the numbers are very
minuscule compared to what it was.
It's dying out.
By the way, we're doing very well in vaccines
and therapeutics also.
I think there's going to be some big announcements
on that in the not too distant future.
But no, we're not concerned.
Actually, Oklahoma has had a very low rate,
relatively speaking.
It is a little spike, a small spike for a
specific reason.
But no.
We had over a million people apply.
They have people now days ahead, lined up.
They have big lines of people.
So Trump said the numbers are minuscule.
The numbers are not minuscule.
We were at one point seeing 30000 new cases
a day.
We are now seeing 23000 new cases a day.
That's not minuscule.
As I've already told you a bunch of times
this week, many states are seeing record spikes.
Texas, Florida, Arizona, etc.
We have more than 20000 new cases every single
day, people being diagnosed with Corona virus.
But there is something that is truly chilling
about Donald Trump saying it will eventually
go away.
Eventually it will go away.
And his followers are so ignorant and so desperate
for Donald Trump to be right that Trump, in
a sense, is correct.
It will eventually go away and his followers
are just ignorant enough that they might give
him the credit for it or at least say, look,
Trump was right all along.
Now, let me explain what I mean by that.
Eventually, even without a vaccine.
Eventually, if the virus keeps spreading and
spreading and spreading.
You're going to get to 70 percent of the country
getting the virus.
And that is the threshold that is believed
to be the threshold for herd immunity, for
something that is contagious to the degree
that corona virus is contagious.
Now, this is important to understand.
Herd immunity is not a fixed number for a
more contagious disease.
You need a higher percentage of immunity to
get to herd immunity.
So measles is so contagious that the estimates
are you need 95 percent immunity to have herd
immunity.
Corona virus is less contagious, as far as
we know, than measles dramatically so.
And so it is estimated that you need about
70 percent immunity.
Now, that could be a combination of vaccinations
and people who got and recovered from the
disease.
We don't have a vaccination right now.
So in order to get the 70 percent we would
have of three hundred and thirty million Americans.
Two hundred and thirty million would be infected
with a roughly point seven percent infection
fatality rate.
That means about one point six million people
would die.
So Trump is right.
Eventually it will die out because so many
people will have gotten it that somewhere
around a million and a half will have died
and we will have herd immunity.
That doesn't mean Trump is handling this correctly.
That doesn't mean it makes sense to have a
crowd of 10000 people in Tulsa, Oklahoma,
on Saturday.
And it certainly doesn't mean that Donald
Trump deserves to be reelected.
So my view continues to be.
If Trump gets another 12 to 18 months, this
could wind itself down on its own, leaving
untold death in its wake.
And you will have Trump ists who will be reinvigorated
and say Trump said it would go away and it
went away.
I guess he was sort of right.
We can't take any chances on that.
Donald Trump needs to be removed in November.
We have four and a half months until the election
and then it's two and a half more until he
would be replaced with Joe Biden, meaning
in seven months total.
Right.
We're talking about January 20, 21st, 20th.
We could have Trump gone Corona virus.
Will it?
In all likelihood, still be a problem at that
point in time.
But we could at least start to start to go
back to something that would actually resemble
sanity at that point in time.
In terms of the decisions you have to make
over the next two weeks, I would go with Foushee
over Trump if if you would go with Trump over
Foushee.
I want to know why.
If Trump says it's safe to go to a rally with
10000 people and Foushee says it's not, I'm
going with Foushee.
I also live in Massachusetts where there are
no rallies of this size taking place.
There are no events of this size taking place.
And that's a very, very good thing.
We have a fantastic program coming up for
you today.
I will remind you that you don't have to just
watch clips on YouTube or Facebook.
If you don't want if you prefer a daily one
hour audio podcast, it's available for free
on iTunes, Stitcher, Google Play, Pandora,
Spotify, etc..
I think I'm forgetting some.
And I encourage you to subscribe to the podcast.
You can also let me know your thoughts about
what is safe and what is not safe.
As of right now on Twitter, I'm on Twitter
at David Pakman.
You can find me there.
Just don't troll me.